hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
or manga and today we're going to take
some time to talk about demon slayer or
more accurately what i've experienced of
it to this point so for quite some time
now people have been asking me to watch
and read demon slayer and make content
on it and while i can't promise that i
did decide to finally take the plunge
and my first impressions of the series
are pretty damn favorable actually to be
clear at the moment i'm 7 episodes into
the anime adaptation which is already a
very very good sign because usually if i
don't like or I'm feeling a bit about
something I will have dropped it and
forgotten about it by episode 5 at most
however in regards to Demon Slayer I
suspect I'll be picking up the pace and
devouring this very much as quickly as I
can
I was pretty hooked from the get-go
because it's always nice to see a dark
Shonen that isn't afraid to explore some
of the more grim aspects of life and I
especially appreciate the tone and
atmosphere set by the anime I think it's
done a wonderful job at creating a world
that is very familiar and yet radically
different which makes me all the more
keen to explore it further as for the
premise I quite like the brother-sister
dynamic going on here I mean it feels
like a very standard Shonen plot in some
ways The Reluctant here are called to
action by a tragedy and working towards
writing something you say this idea
explored in a million other series but
so far it's being done exceptionally
well here and I'm more than happy to be
on board for the ride
the main character Tonto is similarly
familiar he has a lot of classic Shonen
tropes going on like the inherited
special skill and the drive to push
oneself beyond standard human
limitations but at the same time he
brings a wonderful level of depth for a
protagonist and he's very easy to
empathize with and cheer for as a result
as for his sister and driving for snow
Zuko I can't really say have spent
enough time with her to form a proper
opinion I mean most of the time I've
known her she's been asleep and I'm
preparing myself for the potential that
that's how she'll spend most of the
series as well although I really hope
that's not the case at the moment I'd
say that she's simultaneously cute and
heartbreaking it's absolutely adorable
to see her do things like dig a hole to
rest in but shortly after that effect
wears off and the reality of her
situation very quickly sets in what I do
really like is that no Zuko seems to be
the more literal representation of a
core idea of the series which is the
bloodlines between humans and demons I
mean so far the series has gone to great
lengths to try and state how radically
opposed these two existences are and yet
most of what it's actually showing us
says the exact opposite Naza KO is the
prime example of that being at once
human and demon but it seems to be a
very common theme I mean in the most
recent episode I've seen I got quite a
shock when tonzura found
boyo whose dam I think is Mouzon cubits
ooh gee I don't know I haven't spent
enough time with him yet but I was
shocked that he had a human family you
know this figure who has been built up
to be the most evil existence we've seen
thus far
we're shown to be living a somewhat
peaceful life with the human family now
of course I have no idea how real any of
that is or whether or not he cares for
them at all but the point is that the
series is throwing that idea out there
it also does this rather nicely by
humanizing select demons in fact
actually I think that every major demon
that tandro has come across so far for
me has heard the humanizing moment the
most obvious one being the big fat arm
demon who even got a short flashback and
tandra went so far as to comfort him as
he died and I love that sort of stuff
because the series like this can really
run the risk of becoming very boring
very quickly through flight antagonists
especially when you're dealing with
demons because there's often no attempt
to try and make them anything more than
what they're perceived as which is
otherworldly killing for the fun of
killing beings demon slayer thus far has
done a very good job of actually making
me care about the primary demons we've
faced off against to the point where
it's often a shame when they do
eventually need to be killed so I'm very
interested to see where this goes in the
future and whether or not this line of
humanity and Amonte is going to be
blurred even more to the point where
it's completely flipped and there are
some humans out there who are more
monstrous than demons or even if there
are demons out there with more
protective human qualities I don't know
if I'm hoping for too much there from a
shounen series the Demon Slayer has
gotten off to a very solid start so my
imagination is sky-high and something
else that I love about the anime
specifically is the beautiful way in
which it depicts things like tandra a
sense of smell or his sword techniques
would the wonderfully stylized water I
mean I'm sure that's probably how its
depicted in the margaret's well but the
anime makes these scenes flow
phenomenally to the point where I
classify them as a class a visual feast
so I'm always excited when Tantra goes
into battle because I know that aside
from some great action I'll probably be
seeing some cool stylized water as well
furthermore the music is near-perfect
and absurdly important in contributing
to the atmosphere of the world for want
of a better explanation I'm horrible
with music but it feels deep as if it's
old and established like the world
itself and it adds that layer of
believability and immersion to any given
location or situation it's also pretty
hard to ignore the opening and ending
songs because you can never go wrong
with Lisa
I mean her opening was quite possibly
the only saving factor behind the first
sword out online series I think it was
called crossing field and you know just
thinking about it makes me want to
listen to it again I was also a huge fan
of what she did for the various fate
series so to have both an
opening and then ending from her here is
a real treat but yeah there's not a
whole lot more to say really at the
moment I don't have any major criticism
of the series I think it's moving at a
nice pace and giving our primary
characters the time they need to really
establish themselves before providing
too much of an extended cast which from
the opening I know is probably
inevitable and I do look forward to it
but right now I really am enjoying the
more small-scale character focus
actually just before I move away from
this something else I'm really enjoying
is the prominence of masks in the series
I am a huge fan of masks so suck kanji
was an instant favorite of mine as was
the bladesmith who arrived wearing the
clown mask he was a nice bit of fun as
well and it is good to note the Demon
Slayer despite its dark wanderings is
not devoid of humor there are nice
moments of laughter even if it's only a
small chuckle and I think that is very
necessary to break up the tone here and
there but that's about it for now I'm
going to win this video so that I can go
and continue watching the series and
I'll probably post a final thoughts
about it once the anime has concluded
and if it continues to hold my interest
and I'll probably move on to the manga
as well whatever the case exciting times
ahead and that pretty much does it for
my first impressions of Demon Slayer if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produces in general then
please do consider donating to the new
ultra view patreon because the support
of all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
plot the channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ori takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on Demon Slayer
this has been the new world review and
I'll see you next time
you
[Music]